best best guy and you know
um he's awesome
Paul Rudd shares an update on Jeremy
Renner as he continues recovering from a
snowplow accident
on New Year's Day Renner was seriously
injured he landed in the hospital in
critical condition but after undergoing
surgery and a 14-day stay he was
released he is still in all of our
thoughts every day Jeremy Renner have
you spoken with him is he in good
spirits how's he doing I talked to him
yesterday yeah yeah yeah yeah he's he's
doing all right he's doing he's doing
well he's the best best guy and you know
he's awesome of course Paul and Jeremy
are both in the MCU I'm not ready for
this I'm game
I'll do it
while we wait for them to share the
screen again fans can get excited about
Paul's latest Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania hitting theaters February
17th you may not want her to watch this
we had a deal
[Music]
you thought you could win is
Kang more dangerous than Thanos this is
a good question
I mean I've gone up against both of them
uh look they're both pretty tough
but I would say that Kang is somebody
you really don't want to mess with the
mess not that you want to mess with
Thanos but hang has uh diplomatic Kang
has some has some
there's some things about Kang that are
truly terrifying
thank you
[Music]